let's bring in Mike Florio from pro
football talk on NBCSN
Mike good morning how are you well just
trying to sort out this Josh Allen
situation should he have done should he
have gone through and done interviews
today well I I don't know that there's
an easy way for him to dig out of this
hole and look he's a young kid still and
he was even younger and stupider when he
did that the tweets six seven years ago
III don't I don't know at this point
what you do to undo the damage and the
problem is I think somebody must have
timed this to cause maximum mayhem right
whether it's a rival agent could be
somebody from a team that loves him and
wants to get him and you know what let's
drop this stuff out there so he slides
down and we can grab him I mean there's
all sorts of dirty things that happen
around the draft millions of dollars
riding on it futures of franchises and
it's just it's look I don't want to
defend the content it is what it is but
for it all to come up now it puts him in
the worst possible spot to try to sift
through it so you got to ask yourself am
I gonna make it better is there a chance
I'm gonna make it worse if there's any
chance I'm gonna make it worse it's
better to say nothing how do you think
teams are gonna react to this tonight I
think it just depends upon what each
individual team thinks how they assess
at what their owner thinks what the
coach thinks what's what the GM thinks
and you know yeah I am inna mum if
there's a team that calls
Josh Allen's agent says we want to get
him on the phone base you better get on
the phone with them and if they have
questions he'd better answer them or
they're just going to say forget it we
aren't we don't want this guy so even if
he doesn't say anything publicly he
better be ready to talk privately to any
team that wants to to talk to him about
this and figure out what happened of
course the broader issue is and the the
lesson to be learned apart from not
saying stupid things ever especially on
social media but when you know you're
going to be occupying a huge platform
you got to go back and clean that stuff
up and you'd think that the agent would
tell the players and if they haven't now
they need to tell them going forward you
got to go back and clean those things up
what should the Browns do tonight what
will the Browns do tonight well I don't
know what they're gonna do isn't that
fun I think teams have embraced the real
they show component of this there was a
time Dan when they would not only tell
us who they were going to take they'd
sign into a contract before the draft
what fun is that when the draft begins I
think the Browns who have been unable to
fascinate us with their performance on
the field have decided hey if we can
fascinate people with not telling them
who the number one pick in the draft is
we'll do that instead and I there's like
a twinkle in John Dorsey's eye I've
noticed when I talked to him about it
they don't want to tell anybody because
they like the fact that everyone wants
to know something about the Browns and I
this Baker Mayfield thing and there's
just thought about this kid and you know
when you think of the intangibles what
did the Browns need and if all things
are relatively equal and it really is a
crapshoot
we know it's a crapshoot John Schneider
the Seahawks GM had some great comments
earlier this week about the Aaron
Rodgers experience when he was in Green
Bay in 2005 as Rodgers is falling the
Packers don't know what to do they
haven't done the work on the guy they're
scrambling what why is he falling do we
take him do we not take him and they
take him and ends up being one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time so if
all things are relatively equal there's
just something about Baker Mayfield that
fits with what the Browns need they need
a full reset on that franchise they need
a guy who's gonna come in there with
attitude and swagger and and I just I
feel like for me and many others it
changes instantly the perception of that
franchise if they take Baker Mayfield
and who knows but if they do I think
it's going to be one heck of a story
quarterback you don't like yes and I
have Chris Simms every day telling me
the virtues and and the benefits and the
upside of Josh Allen and and I
understand that if you play for a bad
team the product is gonna be bad but
look at his games last year he had like
four games with under a hundred passing
yards how does that happen if you're a
great quarterback I mean I guess if they
just have you hand the ball off all the
time it happens but if you're a truly
great quarterback he's gonna be a great
NFL player I feel like we're gonna see
more of that through the college
experience no matter how good or bad the
team is that you play on and that's one
of the rules of thumb I've heard over
the years you got a
dominant at the college level to have
any chance of being dominant at the NFL
level and these issues with his footwork
I know he says he's fixed them but he's
got accuracy issues footwork problems
and I feel like while there's a chance
he could be truly truly great there's a
greater chance that that it's just going
to be another one of these guys that a
few years from now we're talking about
him like we talked about Blaine Gabbert
Jake Locker Christian Ponder and all the
other guys that came in with a lot of
hype and promise and washed out without
doing much of anything
what should the Giants do it - I'd take
say Kwan Barkley I really would I would
not take a quarterback and I think when
Eli Manning comes out and says 37 isn't
old that's his code for don't take a
quarterback I intend to be here right so
I and and Tony Dungy made a great point
a few weeks ago he said that when he was
with the Steelers in the early eighties
they really liked Dan Marino but they
didn't want to have an awkward transfer
from Marino to Bradshaw Bradshaw to
Marino so they didn't do it so it comes
down to what do the Giants think of
these guys and I don't think there's a
guy that they feel strongly enough about
that that they'd be willing to deal with
the the back page of the tabloids and
the constant questions of when does Eli
Manning give way to the guy that they
took at number two instead you get
Barkley he makes your offense better
he makes Eli better Barkley Odell
Beckham jr. are you kidding me you don't
need an offensive line at all if you got
those two guys and I think that Barkley
makes the most sense for the Giants at -
do you make anything of Schad Khan
Jacksonville's owner buying Wembley
Stadium as to having a great home field
for an NFL team relocating there well
you know the knee-jerk reactions gonna
be that yeah hey the Jaguars are gonna
move to London and they're gonna say all
the right things that they're not gonna
leave Jacksonville but play this out at
some point that Stadium
in Jacksonville needs to be replaced and
when Schad Khan and the Jaguars start
asking for taxpayer money to build a new
stadium what if the politicians gonna
say I think I say you bought a stadium
in London why do you just buy some here
right so you quickly reach impasse over
the amount of taxpayer money that you
want and they can't get a deal done so
you move the team to London and sorry
it's not my fault the people in
Jacksonville didn't want to provide the
money
to build the stadium to keep the Jaguars
here and it won't surprise me if that's
the way it goes and if I'm an owner of
another team that's hoping to get
taxpayer money every time an owner buys
his own stadium I cringe because I know
I'm gonna have to deal with that now
when I try to shake free money out of
the trees because you've got Stan
Kroenke building that five billion
dollar complex and paying for it himself
in LA and you've got the Patriots that
own their stadium and now you've got a
guy who owns a stadium in another
country it just makes it harder and
harder to get taxpayer money and I'm not
saying it's right to get it I'm just
saying from a business standpoint these
owners like to be able to get it if they
can this is gonna make it even harder
thank you Mike have fun tonight we
appreciate your time all right Dan take
care Mike Florio Pro Football Talk
compro football talk on NBCSN for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]